다시 돌아오신 걸 환영해요, Quantum Computing in Practice. 오늘은 에피소드 6이에요. 제가 정말 좋아하는
양자 컴퓨터 응용 분야 중 하나인 자연 시뮬레이션에 대해 집중적으로 다뤄볼 거예요. 이번 에피소드에서는
어떤 종류의 양자 역학 문제에도 적용할 수 있는 단계들을 설명할 거예요. 양자 역학 문제란 어떤
양자 시스템의 상태가 시간에 따라 어떻게 변하는지 찾는 문제예요. 먼저 큰 그림으로 살펴보고, 구체적인 예시를 통해
자세히 살펴볼 거예요. 바로 양자 유용성을 입증한 2023년 IBM 실험이에요. 간단한 동기 부여로
시작하자면, 양자 컴퓨팅 분야에 있는 우리가 계속해서 반복하는 가장 유명한 이야기 중 하나가 있어요.
바로 Richard Feynman이 1959년 Caltech에서 강의를 하면서 기본적으로
수십 년 동안 이 분야 전체에 동기를 제공한 이야기예요. 그 강연의 제목은 "바닥에는 충분한 공간이 있다"였는데
재미있는 제목이지만, 기본 아이디어는 미시적 수준에서 아직 발견되지 않은 풍부한 물리학이 많다고 주장한 거예요.
그때 그 이야기는 큰 주목을 받지 못했어요.
그러다 80년대에 기술이 상당히 발전하면서 주목받기 시작했어요. Feynman은
시간이 지나면서 자신의 메시지를 더 명확히 다듬었어요. 그는 80년대에 Caltech으로 돌아와서
"컴퓨터로 자연 시뮬레이션하기"라는 또 다른 논문을 발표했는데, 여기서 그는 컴퓨터가 자연과 정확히 똑같이 할 수 있는
정확한 시뮬레이션의 가능성에 대해 이야기하고 싶다고 구체적으로 밝혔어요.
본질적으로 원자 수준에서 일어나는 일에 대한 조잡한 근사를 없애고, 이를
양자 물리학을 이해하고 활용하는 컴퓨터로 대체하는 거예요. 자연이 하는 것을 단순히 시뮬레이션하는 것이 아니라 에뮬레이션하는 거죠.
이전 에피소드에서 보여줬던 타임라인 그래픽을 기억하시나요? 한쪽 끝에는 쉽게 해결할 수 있어서
양자 컴퓨터의 속도 향상이 필요 없는 문제들이 있어요. 반면 다른 쪽 끝에는 아직 우리가 갖지 못한
내결함성 양자 기계가 필요한 매우 어려운 문제들이 있어요.
다행히, 우리는 현재 작업할 수 있는 중간 영역에 꽤 많은 시뮬레이션 문제들이 있다고 생각해요. 그래서
이 전망에 흥분되고 흥미를 느낄 이유가 많은데요, 자연 시뮬레이션이
많은 흥미로운 응용 분야의 기초가 되기 때문이에요. 몇 가지만 예를 들자면, 자연을 더 잘
시뮬레이션할 수 있다면 새로운 소재 발견을 가속화하고, 더 나은 의약품과 의학을 만들거나
입자 물리학이나 우주론의 새로운 물리학을 탐구할 수도 있어요. 하지만 여러분이나 저 또는 누구든 이런
흥미로운 분야에 양자 컴퓨팅을 적용하려면, 우선
전형적인 시뮬레이션 기반 워크플로우의 기본 단계들을 이해해야 해요.
먼저 관심 있는 양자 시스템을 파악해야 해요. 이를 통해 시간
진화를 지배하는 해밀토니안과 초기 속성이나 상태에 대한 의미 있는 설명을 알 수 있어요.
그런 다음 이 상태의 시간 진화를 구현할 적절한 방법을 찾아야 해요. 이 재료들이
정리되면, 다음 단계는 실제 실험을 수행하는 거예요.
일반적으로 시간 진화 알고리즘의 quantum circuit 구현을 최적화하고,
circuit이나 circuit들을 양자 하드웨어에서 실행하고 결과를 후처리하는 과정이 포함돼요. 그래서
시뮬레이션 실험에 관련된 기본 단계를 다음과 같이 정리할 수 있어요.
시스템 해밀토니안 파악, 해밀토니안 인코딩, 상태 준비, 상태 진화,
circuit 최적화, circuit 실행, 그리고 후처리예요.
이 단계들은 꽤 자세한 내용이에요. Qiskit 패턴 프레임워크의 네 단계를 기억하시나요? 이 프레임워크는
Qiskit에서 루틴을 구현하는 방법을 이해하는 데 도움을 주는데, 매핑, circuit 최적화, circuit 실행, 그리고
후처리로 구성돼요. 그래서 여기서 처음 네 단계는 실제로 모두 매핑이라는 큰 범주에 포함되는데, 그래서
우리가 이 첫 번째 단계 전체를 한 에피소드로 다룬 거예요. 못 보신 분들은 이전 에피소드로 돌아가서 봐주세요.
이제 코딩에 들어가기 전에 이 단계들이 실제로 무엇을 의미하는지 먼저 살펴봐요. 시뮬레이션 실험을 수행하기 위해
가장 먼저 해야 할 기본적인 일은 시스템을 설명하는 해밀토니안을 파악하는 거예요. 때로는
이미 잘 알려진 것들도 있고, 전체 시스템의 작은 부분들의 에너지 기여를
이해해서 조합해야 할 때도 있어요. 여기서 hi는 h의 n개 부분 시스템 중 하나에 작용하는 해밀토니안이에요.
또한 기본 입자를 다루는 경우에는 시스템이 페르미온으로 구성되는지 보존으로 구성되는지 확인해야 해요. 다음으로
해밀토니안을 인코딩해서 양자 컴퓨터가 이해할 수 있는 형태로 변환해야 해요. 보통
이런 해밀토니안들은 기본 입자나 스핀 시스템으로 구성돼요. 페르미온이나 보존을 시뮬레이션하는 경우,
Jordan-Wigner 변환이나 Bravyi-Kitaev 같은 인코딩 변환을 선택해야 해요. 이런 변환들은
원래 구성 요소인 페르미온이나
보존의 형태로 작성된 해밀토니안 정의를, 양자 컴퓨터의 gate로 쉽게 변환되는 파울리 연산자로 변환하는 방법을 알려줘요. 예를 들어 Jordan-Wigner
변환은 여기서 정의된 것처럼 페르미온 연산자에서 파울리 연산자로의 매핑을 제공해요. 이미
스핀 1/2 시스템을 다루고 있다면, 이는 매우 일반적인 경우인데, 가능한 정규화 계수를 제외하고는
인코딩 체계를 사용할 필요가 없어요. 원하는 해밀토니안을 양자 컴퓨터의
gate 세트로 인코딩한 다음, 시뮬레이션을 시작할 적절한 초기 양자 상태를 결정하는 것이 중요한 다음 단계예요.
이 상태는 이상적으로는 연구 중인
시스템의 물리적 의미나 구성을 반영해야 해요. 예를 들어, 분자의 바닥 상태 에너지를 탐구하는 데 관심이 있다면
Hartree-Fock 근사나 실제 바닥 상태와 상당히 겹치는 쉽게 준비할 수 있는 다른 상태로
시작할 수 있어요. 초기 바닥 상태의 선택은 VQE 같은 변분 알고리즘의 수렴뿐만 아니라
변분 양자 솔버의 정확도와 효율성에도 영향을 미쳐요.
양자 위상 추정의 시간 진화나 샘플링에서도 마찬가지예요. 본질적으로 초기 상태는
계산의 출발점으로, 양자 시스템에 대한 유용한 관측량을 추출하기 위한
무대를 설정해요. 여기서 ci는 계산 기저 상태이고 ai는 임의의 n qubit 상태 준비예요.